our towns and cities just weren't built
to be this hot baked by the sun with
little shade urban living can be
stifling
at mossborne parkside academy in east
london the children are well drilled the
school is victorian and keeping the
classrooms cool is a challenge
all our windows are open and as much as
possible before and after school and
during the day we have blackout blinds
so we actually have them closed when the
children aren't learning and just to try
and keep those classrooms as cool as
possible temperatures could top 40
degrees in parts of england early next
week but in the cauldron of the concrete
jungle the heat is intensified still
further studies have shown the centers
of london and manchester can be 10
degrees warmer than surrounding rural
areas it's an effect called the urban
heat island and with a thermal imaging
camera you can see it in action
the brick the concrete the asphalt is
all glowing red hot as it absorbs the
sun's radiation and stores it as heat
but look at the contrast of a tree it's
not just the shade beneath which is a
cooler blue but the leaves themselves
are kind of in between on that color
spectrum as they're absorbing some of
the sun's energy but evaporating water
keeping them cool and the surrounding
air
data given to sky news shows how that
makes a difference even in a relatively
small town sensors dotted around
guildford in surrey show the heat rising
on monday morning by early afternoon the
temperature in the built-up area was
seven degrees higher than a nearby park
and it took longer to cool still three
degrees warmer at midnight you will not
feel comfortable you know the thermal
comfort is an issue but if you are an
elderly or having any pre-existing you
know the the conditions so you are
higher at risk for the heat stroke or
cardiovascular or the respiratory you
know
the impact and that can be fatal that
can be fatal
90 of the uk population is expected to
live in an urban area by 2050. the
charity trees for cities is planting
shade for the future but warns it can't
do it fast enough there's never been
more focus and funding for trees in
general which is fantastic we should
recognize that but
a lot of that funding historically has
been focused on on the the royal
environment on the countryside and we
believe that we need to shift that
balance
in order to invest much more into our
cities
the government says it wants to plant
150 000 trees in urban areas but the
money for this year has already run out
the sooner they go in the ground the
greater the shade and the even more
intense heat waves of the future
thomas more sky news